you know one of the things I like to do
really is to do kind of like a
comparative analysis not so much an
analysis just comparison of of what
Bernie Sanders is really just trying to
do in America versus what people say
he's trying to do versus what
conservatives tried to say he's doing
let me start by saying Bernie Sanders
and Alexandria Ocasio cortes they are
not socialists I think it's fine to call
them socialists because it's really
beneficial for moving the Overton Window
to the left a little bit because the
more they make you afraid of Bernie
Sanders in aoc or the more we talk about
them the more they call them socialists
the more people become immune to to that
word being a pejorative like it doesn't
scare anybody anymore
but Bernie tweeted out something
yesterday that I want to discuss and
it's in the broader context of a move by
aoc Alexander kosnov Cortez who teamed
up with Bernie Sanders in order to put a
limit on how much interest banks and
lenders can loan can charge to people
that they have loans out with and and so
right now where I think the cap might be
somewhere around 26% a 30 percent or
somewhere high they're looking to get
the interest rate down to 15% to put a
maximum interest rate of 15% now this to
everybody on the right to conservatives
this is socialism this is terrifying but
real socialism would not say hey guys
listen I think it's okay if we just you
know I think it'll be better for the
economy if we just charge a maximum of
15% that way the free market can keep
going the economy could keep going
capitalism would be fine you know
socialism real socialism would not do
that real socialism are really communism
would say no interest whatsoever
ironically there's actually uh some
Scripture it's funny all the
evangelicals who fancied themselves to
be Christians the section of scriptures
very a lot of scriptures against
charging interest but that's not this
episode so anyway this is
what Bernie Sanders said on Twitter
bring up the tweet for me and says quote
Wall Street bankers say ALC and I are
wrong to advance the long sharp
Prevention Act Act which would put an
end to sky-high
interest rates on loans and credit cards
guess what they're wrong now economists
are joining the fight and they are on
our side and then he shared a letter
that's signed by multiple economists who
say that this is actually a good thing
that not charging sky-high interest is
actually a good thing for the economy
it's a good thing for capitalism and in
many ways Bernie Sanders not being a
socialist really stands out here very
clearly because a lot of the things that
Bernie Sanders is trying to do is to
actually save capitalism from itself
there's a book by that same title
written by former Labor Secretary Robert
Reich the same to save capitalism for
myself this is what Bernie Sanders is
ultimately trying to do this is what
Alexandre Acacio cortes are trying to do
and so if we're going to compare
historically Bernie Sanders at ALC with
anyone
they are mostly you know more closely
compared to FDR who was was a
multi-millionaire who was of extremely
wealthy individual but he you know for
all that he did was nothing like a
socialist he saved capitalism from
itself so you know this whole this whole
idea that conservatives do is nothing
more than a scare tactic obviously it's
a scare tactic that in the long run
could actually benefit the broader
society but every because it pushes the
Overton Window to the left they're there
they're trying to intimidate people
they're trying to scare people into
thinking that a OSI is a scary socialist
well when people actually sit down and
look at her policies they you know they
realize well she's actually nothing more
than a you know you know she's just
trying to get post offices you know you
she's a post office socialist you know
she's trying to get you know more
funding for teachers they're trying to
make sure kids can get a higher
education without going into debt none
of these things are seizing the means of
production none of these things are you
know put
into the free markets or changing our
markets to a command economy versus a
so-called free market and the more
people become familiar with what she's
trying to do the more they know they're
headin light you know actually that's
not a bad idea then the less scary the
term socialism really becomes and I and
I think in that way in the long run
conservatives are doing us a slight
favor but in the short run it's
extremely annoying when they offer they
being Bernie Sanders and ALC offer these
really really docile policies policies
that are going to benefit capitalism
policies that is going to make it more
possible for people to participate in
the free markets like you know one of
the craziest things about capitalism is
that they're lazy capitalists are lazy
they don't want to have to actually
compete for your money what they want is
for the government to take your money
and then to give it to them to you know
directly because if you look at the
policies that Bernie Sanders is
forwarding you know these are all things
that are going to make increased
disposable income for for the majority
of Americans which that disposable
income is going to get poured right back
into the economy but that would mean
corporations would have to work what
they would rather do instead is to just
take your last dime from you whether it
be directly to the government whether it
be through getting subsidies from the
government whether it be corporate
welfare from the government or you know
instead of actually having to make a
product they would rather charge you 30
40 50 percent interest on a loan to go
to school or on a loan to get a car so
this this is this is the reality of
capitalists and the reality of this
entire paradigm is that where they're
trying to scare you about Bernie Sanders
and Al C is like they're they're not
saying you can't charge interest they're
just saying maybe 30% is too high and
maybe we should go to 15% which is still
too high but this is their effort to
save capitalism from itself